we have a voicemail it's two one nine
two david p it's very short it's
succinct here is what the caller had to
say you look like Ellen but you're she
was cool so yeah I look like Ellen
DeGeneres
but apparently despite that fact the
show is still cool in this in this
viewers mind you know this color is not
the first person to point this out I
think we had the exact same voicemail
just about last February there was
another caller who said I look like
Ellen DeGeneres was that one saying it
in a positive way or in a negative way
do you remember I think just like this
caller it wasn't it wasn't positive or
negative it's just a fairly good yeah
despite the fact that you look like
Ellen DeGeneres the show is so sure I
was still good yeah I've gotten Ellen
DeGeneres a couple times now I you know
in the email who people say you look oh
yay
should we say I think it's okay to say
yeah a CNN contributor a Sally Kohn
people write a Pat look like looks like
Sally Kohn on the bonus show today
a Russian LGBT rights group is stepping
up to try to help gay men in Chechnya
we've been covering what's going on in
Chechnya with gay men and the LGBT
community is horrible we have an update
from Finland's universal basic income
trial which is really interesting we've
been covering that for a while and also
the New York Times has done something
that I think is vile
they basically set out to try to
normalize Donald Trump effectively I
don't know how else to say it they asked
for nice things that we can say about
Donald Trump we're going to talk about
that on the bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership that's how you sign up
what else
patreon patreon comm slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge there of as
little as one dollar a month to help
offset the lost revenue from the YouTube
advertiser boycott which by the way I
don't want to bore you with it every day
but it is still going on and lastly if
you ever shop on Amazon go to david
pakman.com slash amazon everything you
buy will then send us a little kickback
5 to 7-percent the big deal it adds up
speak to you on the bonus show